Felton steady as she goes Lou Williams
let it fly from midcourt 45 feet away
team de 3 flurry and somehow have
captured the lead in this basketball
game at 31 to 38 has 11 points in the
third quarter Williams gets it off in
time
[Applause]
clearly got it off in time that's what
he does gets buckets sweet blue is what
they call them we'll be back
[Applause]
keep on going he didn't give up on the
shot after he felt the foul they
question question in it they can't look
at this there used to be a time as soon
as the whistle was blown Lou Williams
get something going to the basket make
the right play if necessary if that
means getting off the ball you do it Lou
has over five guarded by Beal shoots for
the wind
[Music]
this game has brought so much excitement
for me in my lifetime just this to be
here right now the way this game is
going back and forth
and score but every now and then these
shows of woody Oh
Ilyas over yes that's the photo right
there had been the poster available near
you pass broken up one on the timer he
gets it away
[Applause]
Hera's controls it
that's Cochin and that's performance
huge dividends at the end of one period
of play simmers up by 1812 to scoring
finish they lead the Cavaliers 35 to 17
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and Lily Williams one of the best in the
league you do not call timeouts so that
the other team can game plan for you
guys like Lou Williams are so good they
can just figure it out on the flats
exactly what he did took the clock all
the way down and when you're a shot
maker like Lou Williams urch
here it's just fine for you to take that
shot basically it's a buzzer to win the
game not many guys make that shot Lou
Williams is one of them play right there
Louie time to grovel pile he did he gets
the basket ago oh you know what Ralph it
is a prayer but like lose those for Lou
always go in so it's like it's a prayer
for everybody except for him just knows
how to find the rim off balance
defenders on them to close the game
inside the two-minute mark any overtime
[Applause]
that's just an amazing job Pepin he is
unbelievable Ralph McKinney's
fallen-down he runs into him and flips
it in the crazy John
the hand-eye coordination on guys like
Lou Williams is never never a doubt
preset to 14 nowadays millions defended
by Forbes
[Applause]
nine feet away and he gives his team the
lead 40 seconds to go
wants to go to his left going left just
look at the pity pack that ball was
throw back to get us out now settle
three or two Oh Mark Davis will the
official indicated it was a to this foot
was on the line
Ralph the two foot was on the line his
right foot was on the line for a big
finish to the period for the Lakers two
seconds to go Luke Wiggins from midcourt
swings one way and just that quickly it
swings back the other way
Wow didn't leave his hand before the red
lights around the board come up one more
time we watch oh yes that baskets good
Wow
great five seconds summers bringing in
five seconds ago tie games he belts are
fastened Luke Williams for the win
goodness that just happened
move Widow because everybody in the gym
knew blue whales was gonna shoot this
shot easily got it off in time and got
nothing
[Music]
and the play before he gives it up he
says I'm not passing this I mean going
to his left route it doesn't get me
better does he have one more trick up
his sleeve
[Applause]
the
and in this one here they took away two
jump shot eyes teardrop right there
going right oh [ __ ]